he is he is I love everything about him
just you know yeah I think that crop of
kids you're mean that are below me I um
you know I like them in different ways
you know what I mean but you know I
don't I never understood and this is
probably something that's gonna cause a
little controversy but there are certain
Wars that happen with certain
ethnicities that are in comedy like
they're what like yeah like in here's
still there yeah they're like there's
the Hispanic comedy committed like half
the people hate the other half well
there's like all these infighting and
all this hatred the history you know who
brought that for was Ali Wong she talks
about that in her comedy a little bit oh
she does yeah yeah yeah yeah but I don't
see that in Asians really what
no Asian comics
like you say it say what you're gonna
say well that's all Comics though hate
each other I mean not even comedy like
Asians in general like there's so much
beef between Southeast Asians versus
Eastern Asians and even within the
Filipino Community like there's there's
just never-ending beef like but nothing
I'm not in comedy
I mean no just say it and then all right
look at that point okay I love this I
love this game all right so that that
has nothing to do with being Asian
maybe if you're saying like the Mexican
Community like maybe they did uh shows
together as well it's like it's uh it's
being close to somebody that makes you
uh well have a beef with them you don't
have a beef or Comics yeah the reason I
feel like I'm the one that's starting
the beef yeah
so I'm the guy that's why I can't see it
in others because I'm the one that's
starting it it's almost like inevitable
when you have the scarcity mentality
it's like you guys were get Asians had
very few things to fight over there we
go that's what it is scarcity scarcity
but here's another thing too I've heard
endless stories of either Ken or dad fan
like doing like a dragon kick to your
chest like you guys you're right you're
right you guys been beefing forever I
can't attack you yeah Ken Jong yeah it's
hard to believe it's hard to believe
did you fart in his face or something no
no but he did not lose are you guys that
good now
oh we're good now yeah okay oh but we
will never be the same because he uh
he's a friend too yeah and I used to
have him sit in for me on Loveline on
the radio yeah because he's an excellent
physician I'm so pissed he got his
license laps because he was excellent
he's an excellent comedian he's an
excellent guy I just we had a problem
and love to pitch again the Kim's a
comedy reunion having Dr Drew moderate
that I mean I don't want to wear like uh
some sort of like black white stripe
right you would need like um armor yeah
and you would need armor because that
will never happen again it's history is
that when you got kicked in that
particular picture it was in that time
period multiple feuds within the group
yeah time periods but I'm in the middle
of all of it he's a center I'm always
the center of it which sucks man maybe
it's me it's a Taylor Swift song for a
reason is it me let's say let's George
is it me
well I wasn't there at the time I know
but just you just based on the
information that you have do you think
it's me based on the information I've
heard that you uh wanted most of the
money from the con uh from the okay go
ahead it was you and by the way okay
you're the only thing you can't control
so you might as well sit with you but
you've made peace with all of them
that's what I feel like well not the
fourth one there's a very popular Taylor
Swift song and he goes it's me hi I'm
the problem it's me okay it's me hi I'm
the problem it's me
yeah did you guys ever see the video
that Ken Jong did before anybody knew
who he was uh what's it gonna be he's
dant him dancing and stuff and singing
yeah yeah yeah yeah so good so good I
don't talk about him anymore you know
okay you know let's not talk about it
anymore but yeah you need to go I went
on the math singer just to sort of spoof
him and Jenny you should go on the best
singer yeah I would love to yeah no but
Ken and I are good okay me and Steve are
good it's just me when the other guy
isn't good but I would like to resolve
that soon I know you do I really do I
like to resolve that and um I'm the one
that's causing the beef in the Asian
community and I apologize to everybody I
just like it any future Wars so fun any
further Wars it should uh come in the
future or your fault real wars yeah all
right anything coming down to pipe is
what he's asking right now is there a
war yeah I think my problem